would you like to be a father one day
this is kind of couples counseling
um
you know yeah i do i do because i i feel
like um
you know before i was very childlike you
know i play a lot of video games i'm
irresponsible i'm lazy this and that
right but
you know
to be honest with you lex in the last
six months i've really have come through
some breakthroughs
and um i'm in therapy and i'm doing a
lot of things and really self-analyzing
myself and my behaviors
and what i want my desires and i think
ultimately yes i really do
because it's a life experience that um
you know i don't want to be
an old man looking back and going
it's something that i've always was
interested in and i think it's based on
fear because i don't want to um
scar my
child the way my parents scarred me
but at the same time
my parents didn't do the work on
themselves like i am
and they were never about
self-improvement they were just about
they were immigrants you know and they
wanted to put food on the table and um
after that they just went about their
business and i'm not like that i would
never be violent toward my kids like my
parents were
my dad was very physically abusive you
know
there was a lot of trauma and stuff and
so um
you know as a kid i i thought you know i
just would never put my kid through this
so that's why i never wanted it but
i would completely do it differently you
know um
even yelling and and those kind of
things i would be very mindful about
those things and i think that i have
certain things you know i'm not a
sciency guy like you but there are think
life things that i've learned over the
years that i could teach a child
you know about living in the moment or
walking through fear or you know
things that you know things will pass
and just different things you know that
i could i would be a good listener and
um
yeah i would like to
do that
so your uh your dad died in uh
august of 2019. wow
yeah
you did your research
uh yeah it's on your wikipedia
so you said some of it was rough but
what's your fondest memory of your dad
well those memories happened later in
life
um as a child my fondest memory was
my mom because he never spent time with
us so um my mom
made him
take me out one day
and he took me to a park
like he doesn't there was no baseball
glove or baseball or anything like that
and we sat on a park bench
right
and we just sat there for hours
we didn't talk because he didn't know
english that well i didn't know korean
so it's just very you know basic you
know information being you know i mean
how are you
doing yeah i'm okay you know
good good good
that type of thing yeah for a long time
for a long time and then
but the day turned bad because i i
forgot my jacket there
and he yelled at me
there was a bit of a piece together at
that time yeah that was peace but then
what happened was
later in life when i got mad tv
and i was doing
you know in my early years you know i
booked a couple of things like
in 2000 i did the tonight show on leno
and then i did um i got mad tv in 2000
and um wow that was over 20 years ago
and um
that's when they my parents kind of went
huh
you know
because obviously you know
there's some nepotism in hollywood right
but in my case my parents were
straight-up immigrants i had no
connections to hollywood and i came up
here poor
you know with no connections
and i built
it you know i mean through the years you
know and in in that way
i'm very proud of myself because i went
through a lot of [ __ ] hell
and sadness and desperation and all that
stuff and i persevered and i did all
that [ __ ] on my own man i i booked the
tonight show on my own i got mad tv on
my own and when i did those things my
parents were very
proud
but before that did they doubt you oh
yeah
you're not you're not funny
you you
you never
make me laugh yeah right and that kind
of stuff yeah you're never gonna make it
you know i mean you're gonna be poor all
your life you know that kind of stuff
but mad tv he was proud
he died well you know every because it
was a weekly show so on saturday nights
they would watch it and i would yeah and
i would i would play
characters that they would understand
like i did kim jong il at the time yeah
right so they loved that right they
loved you know the things that i would
do the physical comedy yeah and they
couldn't believe in their mind you know
ima imagine
your parents from korea
coming here you know not knowing the
language having a child here right and
in their minds that was never like an
option
right and so when
they see their kid i guess on tv
especially there was no internet too at
the time
the internet had just started
so
to them they were like this is a miracle
in fact when i did the tonight show my
dad called me the next day and asked me
hum
he literally asked me this he goes
how much
did you pay them to do it
he thought that i had saved all my money
like like he thought that like tom
cruise goes up there and goes here's a
grand thanks for having me on like you
know no i go no they asked me like so
all the conceptually
they were just shocked by it so when i
got it and then they were watching me
weekly
mad tv
the producer was like hey have your dad
on
so my dad did
two or three sketches
on television so and that so those
memories i also did a pilot for comedy
central and he was on my pilot
uh pilot for like a show yeah so i did
got picked up but he was on the pilot he
was in the show yeah he was in the pilot
he was on that tv too
on television interesting yeah oh wow
okay yeah yeah so it's like he
he would get residual checks yeah you
know
just change everything those uh nepotism
in reverse yeah yeah it was really
nepotism in reverse and so he
in those those memories are very i have
very fond memories because he had
changed as well he was
no longer that violent kind of guy he
had softened a lot you know i mean but
um
when he died
is when those issues came up you know
like a freight train the bad stuff oh
yeah
and i didn't know what was going on i
was it was really hard
you miss him
yeah
how often do you think about them
every day
obviously a lot of it's regrets
you know what i mean
like what kind of regrets not having
said something or
um not having had a conversation
it's not regrets because even if he was
still alive they're just things that are
impossibilities because of his culture
and the way he was raised but my regret
in life will always be
um having those types of even because i
tried i was with my mom
um a couple of months ago
and um
i looked at her
i had tears in my eyes we're at
starbucks i go mom i just want to let
you know that i'm so sorry
that you
lived in that house and my dad you know
and dad hit you and you survived you
stayed in the marriage because of us
right and you know what her response was
let's go to buka the peppa
she wanted italian food
like it was
it's like there was no
there was nothing there right
and so my regret is is that you know
that they
just wouldn't they'll never be able to
even grasp the concept of that kind of
communication you know what i mean and
i'll never have it um
so that's sad to me you know but there's
nothing i can do about it yeah that
callus that comes with an immigrant
mentality you don't even that emotional
connection is not even there i've had um
my grandmother yeah she there's
something called honda more which is uh
starvation in ukraine in the 1930s
that you had to live through she lived
through world war ii and there's nothing
um like the only way you survive that is
the callous you bring yeah you can't
talk with people that fought in in major
wars they can't
they can't yeah can't talk about it my
mom when she was 12 years old she walked
her little sister my aunt to school
right
she forgot a book so my mom goes to my
little sister my aunt stay here i'm
gonna get my book she ran up she came
back while she was gone a military truck
ran over
my aunt and my mom discovered her body
split in half entrails the whole thing
and my mom and my uncles had to go and
get rice bags to pick up her you know i
mean
and then bury her my aunt you know when
you live through something like that and
also the guilt
because my mom believes deep down that
if she didn't forget that book
that her my aunt would still be alive
right so she carries all this guilt and
this and to survive all that trauma you
have to build a callus
back then they didn't have emdr and
therapists and psychologists and any of
that right so they had to survive so
that's who she is and it's sad to me
that you know i mean
that it'll forever she'll forever live
in that torment
[Laughter]
you